- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
Also make sure to check out and subscribe
to our YouTube original channel,
UCTV Prime, available only on YouTube.
(light music)
- Good afternoon everyone,
my name is Mary Comerio.
I am Professor in the Graduate
School in architecture
and the chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We are pleased, along
with the Graduate Council,
to present Jeff Hawkins,
this year's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock lecture series.
As a condition of this bequest,
we are obligated and happy to tell you
how the endowment came to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
this campus is linked to the history
of California and the Bay Area.
Dr Charles Hitchcock, a
physician in for the Army,
came to San Francisco during the Gold Rush
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1885, Charles
established a professorship
here at Berkeley, an expression
of his long held interest in education.
His daughter Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco
for her colorful personality
as well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish the
professorship at UC Berkeley,
making it possible for us to present
a series of lectures, this
very long and wonderful series
which we have had for many years.
The Hitchcock Fund has become
one of the most cherished endowments
of the University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank You Lillie and Charles.
And now a few words about Jeff Hawkins.
Jeff Hawkins has a multi faceted career
as an inventor, engineer,
neuroscientist, author, entrepreneur.
In his book on intelligence,
he describes his life as
animated by two passions,
mobile computing and neuroscience.
As the founder of Palm and Handspring,
Hawkins was at the forefront
of mobile computing
and developed landmark
products like the PalmPilot
and Treo smartphone.
His lifelong interest in neuroscience
led him to UC Berkeley
as a graduate student
in integrative biology,
and to found the Redwood
Neuroscience Institute,
aimed at understanding
how the neocortex processes information.
In 2005 Hawkins gifted the
Redwood Neuroscience Institute
to UC Berkeley, where it now exists
as the Redwood Center for
Theoretical Neuroscience.
His latest company, Numenta,
brings his two passions together.
At Numenta, Hawkins is developing
new computer technologies
modeled on the workings of the neocortex.
This approach, hierarchical
temporal memory,
allows machines to extract patterns
from complex data streams
and predict what is likely to occur.
The company's latest product is Grok,
a cloud based engine
that makes predictions
from streaming data.
Hawkins hopes that Numenta
will play a catalytic role
in the emerging fields
of machine intelligence.
Hawkins received a BS in
electrical engineering
from Cornell University in 1979.
He came to UC Berkeley
as a graduate student
in integrative biology in 1986.
In 1988 he returned to
the computing community,
ultimately to found Palm computing,
and then continued deep
engagement with neuroscience
through the Redwood
Neuroscience Institute.
The Institute was aimed at developing
a theoretical framework for
the thalamocortical system
and fostered a vibrant
intellectual atmosphere
among researchers, postdocs, and students.
Hawkins' account of the neocortex
on intelligence was published in 2005,
to critical acclaim.
Hawkins was elected to
the National Academy
of Engineering in 2003.
Please join me in a warm
welcome for Jeff Hawkins.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you Mary.
Oh, let's trade places here.
So hopefully this microphone's okay?
Not too loud?
Great.
Thank you Mary for that
lovely introduction.
And it's a real honor to be here.
This is a very
distinguished lecture series
and it goes back for many
years and it's a treasure.
It's a pleasure.
I've been looking forward to
it all year to being here.
So I'm gonna to give two talks,
today and tomorrow,
all about intelligence.
Today is intelligence and the brain and
tomorrow intelligence and machines.
Mary told a little bit
of my story already,
which I was going to introduce here
about how I how I came
to be on this stage,
and so I won't go through that all again.
But I'll tell you a little bit
more flavor about the time I was here
as a graduate student at Berkeley.
This was, it goes back to actually 1979,
when I just came out of an undergraduate,
I got my undergraduate degree,
and I had read the September of '79 issue
of Scientific American, which
was a single topic issue
on the brain and there were stories by
very many famous neuroscientists,
Eric Kandel, Hubel and Wiesel et cetera,
and the very last article was
by Francis Crick of DNA fame.
And Francis wrote, he said,
this is all well and good,
we have all this data
about the brain, we know all
this about the neuroscience
and the neurons and diseases
of the brain of and so on.
He says, but don't be mistaken,
we have no idea what the
hell's going on up there.
And he says, what we're lacking is
a theoretical framework
and this excited me.
It was like oh my gosh
we have all this data
about the brain but we really don't
understand what's going on, how it worked.
You need a theoretical foundation
for it and I said this is something we
should be able to do in my lifetime, it's
something I want to work on and I
basically dedicated my career to that at
that point in time.
And my first attempt was at
MIT where I tried to become a
graduate student there in the AI lab and
they asked me, they said, well they said,
"Why are you here?" and I said,
"Well I want to build
intelligent machines,"
and they said, "That's
great we do too," and then I
said, "But I want to study brains first to
"see how they work," and they
said, "Oh, that's stupid.
"Why would you do that?
"A brain is just a messy computer
and why would you study a
"messy computer when you
could study good ones?"
So I didn't get into MIT and
that's why I snuck into Berkeley because
Berkeley I said I'll just go in as a
biology person, they won't know the
difference and so I
got in, it was actually
the biophysics program
but didn't really matter.
There was no theoretical
neuroscience back then.
And at that time
my first six months here, I took classes
I took Jeffrey Weiner's anatomy class
which was great, I read Kandel's book
twice and I wrote a long thesis
proposal about what I wanted to do as a
graduate student and
Professor Frank Wargulan
was very kind and head of the chairman,
he was the chairman in graduate
neurobiology at the time.
He read it he had some other
faculty read it and he said this is really
good, in fact it's a proposal of what I'm
gonna tell you about in my talk.
And he says, "Unfortunately
you can't do this here."
I go, "What'd he mean?"
I just got all this effort
to come here as a student.
He said, "Well no one's doing this
"No faculty is working on models neocortex
"from a theoretical point of view.
"In fact, I don't know anyone
in the world doing this."
This is in 1986 and he said
as a graduate student you got to work
for somebody in somebody's lab and
there's nobody doing what you want to do.
I was really kind of bummed out and
so what I ended up doing after six
months of being a regular student, I took
the next year and for a course of a year
I would come to Berkeley, I kept my
student status, I'd
come to Berkeley once a
week because I wanted to read papers and
you couldn't, there was no internet back
then and to read papers you had to go
to university library.
So every week I would come
to Berkeley with a list of
papers I want to read, I had to visit
multiple libraries on the campus.
I'd go look at these papers,
I would photocopy the
ones that were interesting to me, I'd come
back home, read them over the course of
the next week, come back the next week
with a set of of other papers I wanted to
do and I did this for about a year.
And it was a very great knowledge
gaining exercise about the history of
neuroscience, I could
study whatever I wanted.
But eventually I had to make a
living and I couldn't do that forever so
that's why I went back to work which I
thought was going to be for four years
but it turned out to
be for about 16 years.
Because I had very fortunate success in
my business life and finally I was able
to extricate myself and I want tell you
one more thing.
When I started the
Redwood Neuroscience Institute, this is a
crazy idea.
How do you start a new science institute?
Who's going to come up,
who's going to show up,
who's gonna be the first one here?
I said, it was not even my idea,
some neuroscientist friends
of mine said why don't
you start this institute?
That's what's required.
I said I can't do that.
I said well you if you help me I'll do it.
And one of the people
helped me was Christof Koch, another one
was Bob Knight at Berkeley.
I talked to Bob who was head of
the Helen Wills Neuroscience Institute
at the time.
I said Bob would you help me do this?
He goes sure, we need a
theoretical component here.
And so from the very
beginning there was a close association
between the Redwood Neuroscience Institute
and Berkeley.
That's a little bit ironic because
the Redwood Neuroscience
Institute was located right
next to Stanford and they didn't want to
really do much with us at all.
But Berkeley was very open so we came
up and we did some classes and we
exchanged students and so on.
So from the very beginning it was a good
collaboration and when it came time
for me to start my own lab and my own
business that Numenta, we had to decide
what to do with the
Neuroscience Institute,
Moving it to Berkeley made a lot of sense.
And Bruno Olshausen who's here
was the head guy who was
helping me out at RNI
and he's now a faculty here at Berkeley.
So the long story, here
I am 30 years into it,
I've been working on this for a long time.
So we're gonna just jump into it.
This is Francis Crick's words.
This is what exactly he wrote.
What is conspicuously lacking is a broad
framework of ideas in which
to interpret these results.
The results he was talking
about were the empirical results
of neuroscience.
He said look, lots of data, no theory.
And this is what I've
been working on and I want to tell you
about the progress we've
made on this so far.
I set out two questions I wanted to solve.
One was what are the operating
principles of the neocortex?
What are the theory behind it?
It's not like an equation
or something like
that, but there's a set of principles.
I also realized that once we had those
principles, we would be able to build
systems that work on those principles.
And we'd be able to build
machines that exhibit
the same principles of the
neocortex and so those two
came hand in hand and they
complemented each other.
The way I go about this is the following.
You start with the brain
and we start with anatomy and physiology.
These are constraints on the problem.
We know a tremendous amount of
how the brain organized
and wired and so on.
These are not things you can ignore.
If we want to understand the principles
of intelligence you need to have to be
copacetic with those
those brain principles.
So this I took this seriously,
very seriously, getting totally embedded
with the anatomy and physiology and
histology of the brain.
Then once you
understand the principles and you can
elaborate them, you can model it and you
can first do that in software which is
what we're doing today
and I'm going to talk
more about that tomorrow, and then
ultimately you can do it in hardware and
we have conversations with people trying
to build this stuff today.
So this is the basic premise.
My today's talk is going
to start with the anatomy
and physiology and talk about
the theoretical principles.
Tomorrow I'm going to
start with the theoretical principles
and talk about how we build this stuff
and where is it going.
So let's start with the brain again.
That's a little bit more visible here.
We're gonna start a little bit
of a history about the brain.
You know if you go back in the beginning
when people really trying to figure out
how the organs of the body worked, people
take tissue and they look at it under a
microscope and everywhere you looked if
you looked at you know a liver or kidney
or muscle you would see cells.
And there's like looking
at peas in a ball.
They're all they are lined up under a
microscope, but when you looked at the
brain it didn't look like that.
It looked like a bowl of
micro spaghetti and it
was not clear in the late 1800s that
actually the brain was
made of separate cells.
This was a question.
And many people thought
it wasn't, they thought
it was some sort of magic tubular
mass of jelly or something like that.
And and it was one of the
most famous neuroscientists
of all time, Santiago Ramon Y Cajal
and every neuroscientist knows this guy,
he's like the king of neuroscientists.
He was a Spanish guy,
he basically mapped out
the entire nervous
system for many species.
Cajal came along with
a new technique that he
didn't discover but he was exploiting
for staining cells where you could stain
completely a cell and
see what it looked like.
And when he did that, he started
making these wonderful pictures.
Here's one of Cajal's
pictures on the right here
of a classic neuron in the neocortex.
And what he showed was that actually the
brain is made of individual cells.
Even though they branch all over the place
and they look like they're
connected, they don't.
The cytoplasm doesn't go
between and it's just like tissue like
everywhere else in the brain.
Now this has become known
as the neuron doctrine,
it's the founding principle of which all
neuroscience is based, is essentially
that the brain is made
of a bunch of cells.
A corollary to that which is not
often stated but we should just get it
out of the way is the brain is not made
of anything else, there's no magic pixie
dust in there, it's just a bunch of cells.
And if we want to understand
intelligence, we need to understand how
the cells interact and what they do.
There's no room for a mind that's
separate from the brain.
There's no room
for a mind that can do extraterrestrial
communications and things like that.
So until we have proof otherwise, until
we've eliminated every other possibility,
we have to think of
everything the mind does,
everything we think of as
humanity is a bunch of cells
doing this in our head.
Okay.
Now already you can see on this picture
that these cells are very unusual.
They have a cell body
which is fairly small
in that picture and they have these
branching arborizations called dendrites
and the connections to the cell where we
seize information, it's all arrayed on
those dendrites, they're not even on the
cell body, at least not
the excitatory ones.
A typical neuron has several
thousand of these connections arranged
along the dendrite, this is a very
complex system, and lots of inputs.
There's another part of the
neuron which I'm going to add to the
picture right now which is the axon.
This is the output of
the neuron and it's a
single fiber where the spikes from
a neuron go out to other cells and you
can see here the first thing is that
the axon spreads locally, it makes
connections to lots of other cells nearby.
Thousands of them typically.
And those connections
are very interesting.
They don't connect back
to the original cell.
They don't connect many to any
particular cell, particular other cell
may get one or two of these guys and
most cells don't get a connection at all
so it's very densely packed in there.
But this we make a lot
of connections locally.
Then the axon typically as shown
in this picture continues on and goes
someplace else and makes more connections.
So it makes a lot of
connections locally and then it goes
elsewhere, it makes other connections.
And this is the the basic idea of what
neurons look like in the brain.
We have somewhere around
30 billion to a 100 billion
of these cells in your neocortex.
And we wanna understand
how they work together.
If you take a, we actually
today have a fairly good idea about how
these cells work, meaning what their
properties are, how their ion channels
work, how they grow and how they die and
all kinds of wonderful stuff like that.
So that's fairly well understood.
We have good models of these cells.
However, in the real
brain we find the cells on
their own don't do much.
You can eliminate any
cell and it doesn't really
matter, it's the collection
of cells that matter.
It's ensembles of cells that matter.
Cells working together.
Here's another picture from
Cajal, and back this is over a 100
years ago he made these pictures but
they're still quite good.
In this picture
you see a quite a few cells in it.
This is still a very small percent of
the cells that you might find in a
region like this.
This is a two millimeter high view of
the cells in a slice of the neocortex.
And already you see some things
popping up here, when we see these cells
in groups we see that they're
sort of grouped in layers.
Cajal labeled these with
numbers on the side there.
You can see those layers are
different by the type of cell types,
by the dendritic arborizations where
they project and so on.
And so there's this layer
effect and it's also
a vertical sort of calmer effect you
can see in this picture as well.
So our goal is to try
to figure out how those
cells work and make you smart.
You know, I didn't say this already
but I'll say it right
now, the brain is a very
complex organ, there's many different
components to it.
My interest is the neocortex.
The neocortex is about 60% of
the volume of your brain.
It's the big wrinkly
thing on top, you know it
sort of surrounds the rest of brain,
it's like a sheath.
It's a thin sheet of cells.
It's like two millimeters thick.
And it's the locus of what you might
call all high-level intelligence.
All high-level vision is in the neocortex,
language whether it's spoken
language, written language.
The mathematics and physics and so on.
My neocortex is generating
my speech right now
and your neocortex is understanding it.
The other parts of the brain are
important and they
interact with the neocortex
in various ways.
My goal is really just to understand how
the neocortex itself works and
we're going to focus our
comments on that today.
Okay, so what we want to do is
figure out, you know, why do the cells
have all these synapses on them?
Which is kind of a mystery and I'm going
to pose an explanation today, and
how do they work in groups like this?
What is the information
processing going on in here?
All right so let's go to that.
Here's the agenda for my talk.
I'm going to talk about the neocortex as a
predictive modeling system.
I'm then going to talk
about three attributes
of the neocortex that in my work and my
company we three years ago we had
a real sort of breakthrough in
understanding these attributes and so
I'm gonna focus on them today.
One is the way the brain
represents information
which is sparse distributed
representations.
The second thing is how
it learns sequences of those patterns.
I'm going to argue that sequence memory
is the primary memory in your neocortex.
And then finally I'm gonna talk about
how the online learning or how we learn
continuously, how the
how the memory formed
in online learning.
All right so let's just
jump right into it.
The neocortex is a predictive modeling
system, so here you see
a picture of a neocortex.
Maybe you can't, imagine that
little line drawing there,
and what it does is it receives
input from your senses.
Now we think of the three
primary senses as vision,
hearing, and touch.
There's many more, in fact, vision itself
is more than one sense.
We think of these as three primary senses.
The first thing you have to know
is that they're not singular senses.
The vision, the retina, is really
like a million senses.
If there's a million fibers
on your optic nerve going
from the retina to the neocortex.
It's not like a picture, it's actually a
million separate little sensors that are
arranged topologically.
The same thing with your
body or somatic senses.
There's an array of
sensors on your body that's
got another million fibers coming at
your brain and your cochlear printer
produces about 30,000, again, individual
nerve fibers coming into the brain.
So you have this massive multi million
bundle of nerves activations coming to
your brain and they're changing very
rapidly, that's what we
mean by high velocity.
They're changing the order of
milliseconds, tens of milliseconds and
hundreds of milliseconds.
It's like a fire hose of
millions of fibers flipping
on and off constantly and this is what
the brain works with, this is it.
Once those patterns enter the brain,
they're no longer light, sound, and touch.
It doesn't exist inside the brain.
It's just patterns of
activity, and the brain
has to build a model of the
world from those patterns.
You start this at birth,
when you're born you have the structure of
the neocortex but it
doesn't know anything.
It doesn't know about Berkeley
or universities or chandeliers or
lecterns or computers or water cups or
toothbrushes or cars.
Anything.
It has to learn everything
in the world, it has to
learn what your environment's like and it
has to build this model of the world.
The amount of things
that learns is amazing,
you're not even aware of
all the things you know.
And it has to build this
from the stream of data.
One thing we can say
once it's built this model of the world
and new patterns come in, it recognizes
those patterns and it does a few things.
One does it makes predictions and I
wrote extensively about this in my book
on intelligence that the brain is
constantly making predictions.
You're not
aware of most of them.
You're constantly predicting
what you're going to see,
what you're going to feel,
what you're going to hear.
If I do a simple gesture just
like putting my hand on this lectern and
I've never done this in
this exact spot before,
as my hand comes down my
brain has expectations.
If my hand went too far and
passed an inch through this lecture and
it would say whoa, something's wrong.
If it felt like water or cold or metal or
jello, it would all say something's wrong.
And you're even thinking about this but
your brain is constantly
making expectations.
You're predicting what I'm going to say.
You may not be able to
predict the exact words.
Sometimes you can, like what
is the word at the end of
this sentence.
But other times it's just
you're predicting actions but if
something is wrong you know it.
And so part of prediction
is also detecting
anomalies in the world.
So we know that the brain is
detecting anomalies as well.
And finally, everywhere you look in the
neocortex it's generating actions.
So again as I said earlier my neocortex is
speaking right now and it's controlling
a high-level action so
other parts of the brain are also doing
behavior but the neocortex is doing
all sorts of high-level behavior.
Okay, so this is what we want to do.
We have this high velocity
data stream building the model.
Now if I were to tell you the
three top attributes, my top three
attributes explaining the principles how
the neocortex works, these are them.
Starting with number one.
It's a hierarchy.
Although it looks like a sheet of cells,
it's connected in a way that is literally
like a hierarchy of regions.
And this has been well
known for a long period of
time here.
Information flows into regions
at the bottom of the hierarchy.
This is a caricature drawing,
it's not a picture of
a real hierarchy in a brain.
It goes into the bottom of
this hierarchy and it flows
up and it also flows back down and it
converges, there's a little opening
and it converges and it comes down.
We also know that these
regions in the hierarchy are
very very similar.
They look the same and it is believed
and we act as if they are the same.
They're actually doing basically the
same thing, there's variations on a theme
here but the regions at different points
in the hierarchy ones are connecting the
vision and touch and hearing are actually
all doing the same thing, they're all
doing the same sort of
information processing.
There's tremendous
evidence to support this.
This was first proposed
in 1979 by Vernon Mountcastle.
So we have a hierarchy of
cortical regions that are
all doing the same thing.
And if they're all doing
the same thing and the whole
thing does prediction model building,
prediction anomaly detection and motor
behavior then every region is doing
those things.
It's building a model of its
world, it's making predictions,
detecting anomalies,
and generating behavior.
So that makes your job
a little bit easier.
Here's a picture of what a
real hierarchy looks like in a brain.
This is a famous,
all the neuroscientists in the room will
know this picture immediately, this is
from Fellerman and Vanessen and it shows
in the macaque monkey some of the
regions in the visual cortex.
We don't need to study this in detail,
there's little colored boxes or different
regions in the neocortex and you can see
there's quite a few layers of them, quite
a few of these guys and they're all
hooked together, different species of
different hierarchies, we don't really
know what the humans look like but it's
probably something similar to this.
We're not going to go
into more detail here
but this hierarchy is a fairly
complex thing and it's real.
Okay.
The second principle here that I argue
is that the primary memory function
which is going on and the cortex is a
memory system, is a sequence memory.
Now I want you think
about this, may not be
obvious to you, but when you are trying
to understand the world.
For example,
you're trying to understand my speech.
The patterns are coming in time.
It's like you're listening to a melody.
The order which the
patterns occur, rapidly
changing order, the rapid change you see
patterns is important.
It's a sequence of patterns.
The same is true when I touch
things and the same is true of my eyes,
I'm constantly moving my eyes in the
world and there's a pattern,
a sequence coming in.
For you to understand
or infer on the world you have to have a
memory of sequences.
Similarly, if I'm going
to make predictions I have to have a
memory of what follows next.
You know, what follows
this, what is typically
after this, and that's a sequence memory.
If I'm going to generate motor behavior,
think about what happens for me
to create this speech right now.
I am creating a very
fast temporal pattern on
dozens of muscles in my voice box that
are going in this complex pattern.
I am not making this up,
I've said these words
before, I've said
sentences like this before.
I'm doing little variations on a theme
here and there, but basically I'm playing
back sequence memory of very complex
sequences and we do this
at all our behavior.
Sequence memory is key to
understanding inference and prediction
and I believe this is the key to
understanding how the hierarchy works.
In fact, the idea basically
is in the hierarchy
is you learn sequences of sequences of
sequences, you go up the
hierarchy, you build stability.
Okay.
The third component here is
the way the brain represents information.
Sparse distributed representations.
It's been known for a long
time that when you look in the
brain you find that at any point in time
most of the cells are relatively quiet
and a few of the cells are very
relatively active.
It's sparse, that's
what we mean by sparse.
It's very few things are very active,
most things are quiet, and
there's a lot of inhibition
that's making this happen.
It's been you know Bruno Olshausen
I mentioned earlier he'd say he wrote
one of the seminal papers on sparse
coding in the visual system, looking at
it from an efficiency point of view.
But only recently that I fully understand
some of the attributes of sparse
distributed representation
and we're going to talk about it.
So everywhere you look in the brain,
even coming out of the out of the senses
you see sparse activity
between regions, within regions,
everywhere you go it's sparse and this
is not an accident.
There are some properties
of sparse representations
which are essential for building
intelligence and I'm
going to talk about them.
Okay so I'm going now go in detail
on two of these items.
I'm not going to talk
further about hierarchy.
I'm going to talk about sparse distributed
representations and I'm talking about
sequence memory, and we're gonna talk
about how groups of cells can learn
sequences of sparse
distributed representations.
So now I'm going to
switch into a little bit more like a
computer scientist mode of thinking here
when we talk about sparse
distributed representations
and I'm going to first tell
you about how representations are used
formed in a computer and then contrast
that to sparse
representations in the brain.
So in a computer we typically use
something called dense representations.
You might think of this, we have a few
number of bits maybe eight like an a
byte or 128 bits or 64
bits, something like that.
We use all the combinations of
ones and zeros, so if I have eight bits I
can use all from 0000000
into 11111111
and everything in between, it's all valid.
The individual bits don't mean
anything, here's an example ASCII code.
ASCII code is an 8-bit code for
letters and so the letter M is
represented by 01101101.
However, if I say to you,
what do those bits mean in an ASCII code?
What does the third bit in that
that encode mean something?
It doesn't mean anything.
It says I have to look at the whole thing.
There's nothing about that
representation which tells me what it is.
There's nothing about
those bits that say M.
It's just an arbitrary assignment.
The bits themselves have to be looked at
as a group and some programmer decided
one time that that should be an M and
we're gonna and the computer
it knows nothing about that.
Now these representations are assigned.
They're not learned, they're just made up
in some sense, and that's a great way of
working on computers.
In the brain we don't have that.
We have sparse distributed
representations.
Let me just tell you what they are.
First of all you have thousands of bits.
Now when I say bits you
can think of cells, okay?
So when I'm talking about
bits it's the same as cells.
When I say we there's
a few active bits, I mean
there's a few active cells.
So I might have thousands of cells
or thousands of bits.
You need to have a large number.
We typically work with 2,000
bits in my work at Numenta.
And there are mostly zeros in a few ones.
We will typically use 2% activation
so we'll have 40 one bits
and 1960 zero bits.
And so this is a sparse representation
I show you example there
just showing a bunch of zeros
going off to the distance here.
Now the difference here
in the brain is that
each bit has some sort
of semantic meaning,
each bit has some meaning on its own.
You just, it's not like this is
an arbitrary bit and or an arbitrary cell,
one moment it means this and
something a moment means something else.
They have some sort of semantic meaning.
We may not be able to figure that out
very easily but there's some sort of
semantic meaning and what we do is we
pick the top bits, the top semantic
meanings for a representation.
And this'll become clear but
let me give you an example.
This is a made-up example for
for analogy, it's not
the way we would do it
and it's not the way
it's done in the brain.
But let's say I wanted to
represent a letter like the letter M in
a sparse distributed representation.
I would come up with 2,000 attributes.
I might have attributes
for this is a vowel or
this is a consonant.
I might have attributes for
where in the alphabet this
letter is.
I might have attributes
for what it sounds like.
Is it O sound or E sound,
is it a hard sound or a soft sound
is it a fricative sound.
I might have attributes how it's drawn,
is it drawn with descenders or ascenders,
is it a closed shape or
an open shape and so on.
And then when I wanted
to represent a letter
I would pick the 40 attributes that
best represent that letter and therefore
the meaning of the letter, the meaning of
the thing is actually incorporated in
the encoding itself.
And that's a really great thing to start.
Now we're gonna have to
learn these meanings,
the brain doesn't know these bit meanings,
doesn't know what the cells represent
when you're born, it has to learn them.
But the basic idea is as I said.
Now there's some great
properties that come
with sparse distributed
representations and
I'm gonna go through those, this is
pretty key to understanding everything
else that's going on.
Let's start with the simplest one.
Let's say if I wanted to
take two sparse distributed
representations and
see if they're similar.
I could just basically line them
up and say if they have similar bits one
bits in the same locations they have
semantic similarity.
If they don't, they're semantically
different and I can see well if I have
41 bits I can be anywhere between no
overlap and 40 bits overlap.
But I can easily compare
them and wherever I have
a one bit in common is
semantically similar.
The second thing is that what if
I wanted to store one of these patterns
and recognize it later?
We're gonna certainly gonna
want to do that in the brain.
We want say oh I've seen this before.
What is it?
How would I go about that?
In a computer we might save all
2,000 bits, but here we're
not going to do that.
We're gonna say look let's just save the
locations of the 40 bits that are one and
we would say in computer language we say
we store the indices of the ones.
So I have a list of 40 indices saying okay
what locations are the one bits and now if
a new pattern comes at
the end I'll say hey
do I have ones in those same locations?
If I find those ones in the same location
I know I have the whole
bit, the whole pattern.
I don't have to look at all the bits.
I only have to look at the ones
that were one before
and know where they are.
That's gonna work very well.
But what if I came along to you and I
said okay, we have a problem.
We can't store the
location of all 40 bits.
All 41 bits.
We can only store 10 randomly.
You can pick 10 randomly but that's it.
And so we now have 10 indices.
We call this subsampling.
And you say well will that work?
If I if I see those 10,
I have those 10 indices, a new pattern
comes in, I say, is this the one I saw
before, is this the one I saved?
I'll go down and say
look, the 10 ones in the
right locations, I'd say that's good.
And you might say well that's not good,
I could be wrong.
Maybe I got 10 of them right
but the other 30 are wrong.
Well that could happen.
It's very very unlikely to happen,
but even if it did
happen what does it mean?
It means I have now made a
mistake but the mistake is for something
semantically similar to the
thing I stored originally.
Even though I didn't get
save all the bits correctly
and maybe a few of them
are wrong, basically
I have a very semantic similarity to the
thing I saw before and that's good enough.
And we're gonna take advantage of
this because we're gonna be, these are
actually going to be connections in the
brain, we don't have to connect
to everything, you only
have to connect to a
small number to be pretty certain we got
the right pattern.
Now the following property
here is one of union.
Imagine I took 10 sparse
distributed representation,
10 2,000 bit patterns and I ordered them
together so wherever
there's a bit I've added it
up with a bit so I have 10 of these guys,
each has 40 bits on or 2% activity,
and I create a new one which is 2,000 bits
which has about about 20% of the bits on.
I just order them together.
This is a one-way operation.
I can't undo it.
I can't say oh given this
union tell me what the
individual bits were.
Individual pattern, I can't do that.
But I can do something very interesting.
Almost as good.
I can say here's a new
sparseness distributed representation.
Is it one of the original 10?
So given the union and a
new one, is it one of the
original 10, and the
answer is I can do that.
I can do it very reliably.
All I have to say are
the ones in the new bit
in the ones in the union
and if they are, then that's good.
You might say well that could be an error.
If you're following this
you might say look I
could get maybe matching up one bit from
one of those 10 and another bit from
another of those 10 and so on.
This is astronomically unlikely to happen.
A little bit of math shows you that.
And so this is a good thing.
Why do we want to care about this?
I said earlier the
brain makes predictions.
What the brain does is
actually it's predicting lots of things
all the time.
It's not predicting one thing,
it's predicting many things and
the way you make some
predictions, we're gonna see
is it makes a sort of
a union of predictions
and we want to know if
something unexpected happens
we have to say hey what
actually happened was one
of the predictions or was it not one of
the predictions?
So I can't always tell
you what my predictions are but I can
tell you if this thing that happened
wasn't correct.
Alright so those are our properties.
If you're going to forget
everything else I talk about today and
tomorrow and you want to remember
one thing from my talk,
we can remember this.
And I'll state this right very
clear, I'm certain of this.
That all intelligent
machines, biological or
otherwise, are going to be
based on sparse representations.
These properties are critical
and they solve some very
fundamental problems that have been
bothering people for a long time.
So sparse distributed
representations is the language of
the brain and that's
what we want to do that.
Okay so now we're gonna do
the next step here, we're gonna
talk about sequence memory.
I already argued why it's important, but
I'm gonna tell you how we learn
sequences of these sparse
distributed representations.
So let's just jump right into it here.
We're gonna do a little
bit more neuroscience.
Here's a picture of our brain again,
a very light picture of our brain.
We're going to zoom in our little
section in the neocortex,
hopefully you can
see that better.
There's a picture of a little
slice of the neocortex.
There you can see these layers going
left to right, those are layers of cells,
and you can also if you're close to this
you can see there's sort of a vertical
orientation of columns in there as well.
We're going to zoom in one of those
layers and look at a little caricature
drawing that I've made here.
Those little circles
represent cells in the brain.
I'm just making so for
illustrative purposes.
And when you look at a section
of a layer of cells in your
cortex you see two principles.
One principle is that, represented by the
green arrow, is that there's
a columnar structure.
The cells that are vertically
aligned in a very skinny column tend to
have the same feed-forward response
properties, they tend
to behave the same way.
Very few connections actually vertically,
but there's a there's a vertical thing.
So if I give an input to the brain,
those cells will all have a similar
feed-forward response property.
The orange thing, the
orange arrow basically
represents where most of
the connections occur.
95% of the connections are just
cells and columns nearby.
So we have a very vertical orientation
in terms of performance, all these cells
in the column are doing
the same thing roughly,
and then we have most of the
connections are horizontal.
If I now zoom in a one of those cells,
this is that little picture of the neuron
I showed you earlier so we
don't to go through that again,
but now I'm going to zoom in on one of
the dendrites and this is a picture of a
real dendrite on a neuron, and if you can
I'll try to walk you through it.
It's a little section.
It's only probably in that
picture maybe 40 microns wide or
something like that, and you can see
there's a branch going on in there and
you can see the actual synapses, the
actual spines where the synapses connect,
those are the little presented
appendages going up and down,
they're really packed in
about one micron apart.
Now these these spines are all over,
these synapses are all
over the dendritic tree.
We've learned something
in recent years which is very important.
That when these these dendritic
regions, you can take a
little section of a dendrite.
It acts in a very unusual way.
When you have a bunch of
synapses active at the same, if I have
one synapse active, it has almost no
effect on the cell body.
But if I have 10 or 20 of them
active at the same time in
the same location, it
has a very large effect
on the cell body.
It's as if they're like
a coincidence detector.
It's like I've had all bunch of patterns
coming in at once.
It says oh that's a whole
group at once, that's good.
If I only have some of them
or a few of them, doesn't do that.
And so this is something
that's a very, very
important property and we're
going to need to exploit that
in our in our model here.
Just to give a little bit
more flavor for that since
this is the neuroscience talk so there's
a little bit depth in
it and I don't hope I
don't lose too many of you here.
If I look at that neuron
carefully we can actually
make a distinguish between
two types of dendrites.
There's the ones that are very
close to the cell body, these are called
proximal dendrites, and if I have an
input there it has a linear effect on
the cell, meaning it's like if I have one
spike coming in and that the cell gets
depolarized a little
bit, if I have two it's
twice as much, and three
and following and so on.
So it's a linear summation and this
is where we find most of the
feed-forward connections
to the cell occurring.
Then there are the distal dendrites.
These are the ones that are
further away from the cell body and they
work like I just said a little moment ago.
There are dozens of these regions,
they're nonlinear
summation, they act sort of
like coincidence detectors and this
is where we primarily find
connections to other cells nearby.
And these are these are
important properties for us.
We are going to model
this with a model neuron.
And this is a fairly
sophisticated model neuron,
this is a picture of the
neurons we use at Numenta,
and it basically models exactly
what I just said there on the left.
You have a cell body which is that little
square, we have the green dots
representing the proximal synapses and
then the blue guys arranged in those
little dendritic segments are representing
the distal synapses and we align them as
a series of dendritic segments,
not in the branch like
we see in the brain but
in an array like that.
And has the same properties.
So we're going to build now,
we're going to build networks with these
guys, and we're going to learn how to
form sparse distributed
representations and
learn sequences of them.
So let's come back to this picture.
We are now going to take
that model neuron I just told
you about and we're going to arrange
them in a layer of cells and in this
picture here in the center bottom, we're
showing a lot of little rectangles, a lot
of little cubes, each one of those is one
of our model neurons, if you will, and
I've shown them in an array like we'd find
in the brain and in columns that are
only four cells high in
this particular case.
And the colors of those cells are
their activation states which I'll talk
about in a moment.
Okay so we want to understand
is how does this structure,
using those neurons, form
sparse representations
and how does it learn
sequences and how does it make
predictions and how does it detect
anomalies and so on.
Which is I think is what
basically is going on
in neural structure.
Okay, so let's now zoom
in on a layer of cells.
You can think of this like the layer of
bits in our sparse
distributed representation
but this is a two-dimensional layer of
cells here, each one of those cells as I'm
showing down here, and we have some
feed-forward input coming from a sensor
from another region in the brain going
into this area.
And that feed-forward
input is going on the
proximal dendrites of proximal synapses
if you will and what we're showing in
the colorization here,
it's just one of our
simulations, the colorization here is
representing the level of input activity
that it's getting.
It's not the firing rate
of the cell, it's just a
depolarization of the cell,
how much input it's getting.
Some are getting more
and some are getting less.
They're sampling from
the input space and the
ones that get the most fire first and
they inhibit the other guys.
And so this little
yellow thing is basically
inhibitory field and basically the guys
who get the most activity are the ones who
inhibit everybody else.
And what we have now is we
have a sparse distributed
representation of our input space.
I won't go through how that is learned and
how it will exactly work because I want to
get to the sequence memory, but this is
how we ended up with this pattern.
So here we have our array of cells, this
is just like our zeros and ones.
The white cells are zeros
and the red cells are one,
those are the active ones.
I'm not showing you
2,000 columns here, only
about a quarter of that just to make
it look visible but you can see I have a
sparse activation here.
Now over time the patterns
on the input change.
This is time one and
okay so here's time two.
So immagine now as I'm speaking, as you're
doing things, these patterns are changing
constantly in these cells.
There are some cells becoming
active and a moment later
other cells are becoming active as the
patterns in the world change.
And this is a sequence and we
want to learn the sequence,
we want to learn like well at
this point how do I pick
what's going to happen next?
And we do that on a cell by cell basis
and here's how.
When a cell becomes active
it says who is active
recently nearby because if they're
active recently nearby and I see them
again, I'm gonna predict my own activity.
So a cell will come along and say look I
just became active, let me look around
and sample from the people who are
nearby who was active just a moment ago.
And we're going to form
connections to that and
we're going to do that on our
distal dendrites down here.
So this is like a coincidence detector.
This is like our index of 10 patterns.
We are going to basically
say I'm going to try to
recognize the previous
state by forming connections
to it and if I see that, I will become in
a predictive state, I'll
predict my own activity.
So if I see this, I'll
Every cell is doing this all the time
and so when a new pattern
comes in, we have all these
yellow states, these cells
in a predictive state,
they're all saying hey I might
become active next, I
might become active next.
Now in this case there's more
yellow cells of predictive states than
there are red ones and that's
because imagine I had some patterns,
I had A followed by B or I had A followed
by C or I had A followed by D.
And if I show you A it's
going to predict B, C, and D.
It's a union of those things.
So that's what you're
basically seeing happening
going on here and this is the basics
of a transition memory or beginning of
a sequence memory because I'm learning
how one state goes to another state.
As I've shown it here,
it has a major flaw.
It's what we call a first order memory,
meaning it only can go
back one step in time
and that means I can't use
information that occurred
a long time ago, all I can
use is what happened earlier.
Let's say my patterns were X, A, B.
Or Y, A, C.
Or Z, A, D.
If I could go back two steps and say oh
it's X followed by A,
then I can predict it's B.
If it was Y followed by
A, I could predict it's C.
And that would be a second order memory.
We want a system that can go
arbitrarily long sequences,
very long melodies if you will.
And this system isn't going to do that so
the way we're going to solve that
problem is we're going to
add cells in the column.
Essentially we're going to use the
columns and multiple cells
to solve this problem and
let me show you how it's done.
Variable order sequence memory.
Let's start with our zeros and ones,
our representation of a sparse
distributed representation.
And I'm now going to assign
instead of each of these bits being a one
I'm going to make it a column of cells.
So I now have 10 cells above it so each
column is now one of my ones or zeros
and I'm going to pick one,
those are supposed to be little
circles above the ones and
zeros, I don't know if it
looks like that to you.
But anyway I have 10 cells
and I'm just gonna pick
for every one bit,
every column that's active
I'm gonna pick one cell
and say that's the one that's on.
And I'm gonna pick that for the
another one bit and another one bit and
I made an arbitrary assignment like this.
I can now do the same thing again in a
different representation, here
is the same representation,
the same ones and zeros, but I'm going to
pick a difference set
of cells in that column.
Now think about this.
I have now the same input
but I'm representing in
two different ways.
At the same time I can say
they're the same because
they're the same columns but
at the other hand I could
say they're different
because I use different cells
And even though some of the
cells might be the same,
nine out of 10 will be different
and that's good enough.
Think of it another way.
If I have 40 active columns
of 40 bits that are one
and I've 10 cells per column, there are
10 to the 40th ways to
represent the same input.
I have 10 to the 40th ways of
representing an A or
10 to the 40th ways of
repeating a pattern or note in a melody
if you will.
And I'll say a sentence here,
I'm gonna use the sound
to in multiple ways.
I'm gonna say there are
too many tutus to count.
Right?
Well I use the same sound coming into
your head over and over
again, the to sound,
but in context your brain has to
represent them differently because it
hears them as different, it
perceives them as different.
And there has to be a way of doing that
and I propose the columnar structure
like this is a perfect way of doing this.
And it gives us a huge capacity.
So now we can go back and we do,
I'm not gonna walk you through all the
details of this, but if I do the same
thing in a column and array of layer
cells and a cell now makes connections to
other cells in this larger assemblage
here we basically build a high
capacity sequence memory.
Every cell is gonna be
predicting its next state
and when they do that we can follow
these and make predictions
and go through time.
I'm going to give you a
little bit more flavor on it,
a little bit deeper so
you can, if it gets hard
you can just I'll come back
to you in a second here.
Something easier.
Part of this theory is that when a
column is predicted or not predicted it
behaves differently.
So if it wasn't predicted
and a new input comes along
and that column is selected,
as far as all the cells
it's like I don't know
which cell is supposed to be active right
now, it's like I'm gonna burst 'em all,
they're all become active.
And this is a way like
you can sort of say hoo,
unexpected thing happened or it allows
you to pick up a melody in the middle of
the melody, something like that.
If if you had good
predictions and you knew
exactly what you're tracking and you knew
exactly where you're going and
everything was working just like you
expected, then you'd only have
activations of one cell per column.
We see this kind of thing when unexpected
things happen in the
brain you see a lot more
activity going on.
So this picture here I'm
going to show you, there's three columns
I'm gonna highlight here.
Two of them,
the two on the left have one cell
predicted that's the yellow state and
the one on the right which is the heart
of the C has no cells predicted and if
all those columns become active in the
next state then you'll see the one on
the right, all the cells in the
column become active
and the one on the left
only one cell become active.
So we can detect anomalies on a sort of
column by column basis, this sort of
attribute by attribute basis.
Okay.
So you put all this
together in ways that you
can read about if you want and you end
up with a very powerful sequence memory.
It's a variable order sequence memory,
it can learn very complex
long temporal patterns,
it makes multiple
simultaneous predictions,
it can detect when what
actually happens is correct or
not correct and it can
tell you why and why not.
It is a high-capacity memory.
I'm not going to prove that to you here or
demonstrate it today but trust me that
you can, a simple memory of just 2,000
columns can learn millions of transitions.
It is a very high capacity system.
And it's very kind of
difficult to max it out.
It's distributed.
Think about this, there's
not a single point of
failure in the system.
I can eliminate columns,
I can eliminate cells,
I can eliminate dendrites,
I can eliminate multiple
ones of those things
and it keeps on working.
It grades gracefully
all the way down because of that all the
properties involved here.
And finally it does
semantic generalization.
What do I mean by that?
Let's say I have a series of
patterns coming in.
And remember these bits
of semantic meaning,
they're learning but they
have semantic meaning.
And I learned some sequence of these
patterns and now I give you a new
pattern and it's the same sequence but
actually it's different elements, they're
slightly different.
Different numbers of some
of them some of the bits are
different, some of the
columns are different.
It'll be able to say you know what,
these are different patterns but I
recognize the sequence, I recognize there
are different spatial patterns coming in,
different notes if you will, but I
recognizes it's the same basic melody
and I will make predictions based on
previous knowledge on a
different environment.
And so it generalizes in a
in a semantic way which is
a very desirable attribute.
Okay.
Now I'm going to the third
attribute I was going
to talk about as part of this theory is
the requirements for online learning.
You know, think about what
does online learning mean?
It means that when data is
coming into the brain,
you don't get the story.
You know when we think about
computers we bring data into a database
and we look at it, but here the brain
doesn't do that, the brain it comes in
and has to learn right away, it has no
chance to store the sensory data coming
from your senses.
It's like I need to infer,
I need to make predictions,
and I need to learn all in one fell swoop.
So online learning is the concept
of that you're continuously learning.
That's the machine learning term for that.
So it's pretty simple actually.
Essentially you have to train on
all the time, all new
inputs have to be trained.
It might be noise, it might be
some thing you're never
going to see again,
but you still have to train
because it might be something you're
going to see again if it's a novel thing.
Essentially if a pattern
does not repeat, then we're going to
forget it and if a pattern does repeat
then we want to strengthen
it and remember.
We model this in a way
similar to our interpretation of what's
going on in the biology.
Let me just walk you through,
here's our model again of a
layer of cells, there's our model of our
neuron, and then over on the right is our
picture of the dendritic
and the spines on it.
The one thing we've learned over the
years, it used to be believed that
learning only occurred in the
strengthening and weakening of synapses.
In fact many people
still they say as rote.
But we've learned that
synapses can form very rapidly.
That I can have an axon
and a dendrite that are
near each other and there's no synapse,
but if they both fire at the same time,
that a new synapse can grow very rapidly
in a matter of minutes or a minute or so.
I mean you can watch movies of this
stuff on YouTube, it's pretty amazing.
So these these synapses
can grow and ungrow.
And so instead of just increasing the
weight or decreasing the weight, we can
grow new synapses which is a much more
powerful concept and so we've adapted
that in our models.
Here's how we do it.
We consider there's two
things about a synapse.
A connection between two neuro cells.
There is the growth of it and then
whether it's connected.
Whether it's connected, the
wait if you will, we make
it binary.
I'm not saying that it's binary
in the brain but it's good enough for
what we need to do so it's either
a connector that's not connected but
however it can grow on a scale,
meaning I can be from no
growth to a little bit of
growth and at some point once it gets
above a certain threshold you say it's
connected and if I continue increasing
this what we call the permanence, it just
gets stronger and stronger, it's harder
and harder for it to forget.
So by training over and over again,
it's not like making the synapse stronger
as much as it's making it
harder to forget this thing.
And there's a lot of, we didn't make this
up, there's a lot of evidence for this,
I read a paper once where someone
suggested this idea and we've adopted it.
Okay so that's basically the system
we've come up with.
When we simulate this stuff in our work,
we typically as I said we
had like 2,000 columns,
we typically use about
30 cells per column, each cell has about
128 dendritic segments,
each dendritic segment
can have up to 40 synapses on 'em,
these are numbers that are right in
the range of realism on real neurons.
And what you end up with then is
you've got 2,000 columns
in one of our simulations, 60,000 neurons,
5,000 synapses per neuron, and about
300 million synapses total.
This would be equivalent
to a very small section of
the neocortex but it turns out is
a very robust and powerful tool for
discovering patterns in
complex data streams.
And we build we build hundreds
of these models every day in my
office because we're in a production
system so they really work.
Okay so now I'm going to
basically sort of go back
to where we started from.
Say well we're trying to
find a broad framework of
ideas in which to interpret the
neuroscience empirical data.
And the question is how
good are we doing on this?
And you know we have a long way to go
but I'm also pretty happy with how far
we've gone so far.
So here's some of the
things that I didn't know
30 years ago.
Maybe someone else knew
them but I didn't know them.
We now know that the neocortex build a
predictive model of the world, it's a
memory system, it's not a computer,
and that system must be trained.
In my book I called this
the memory prediction
framework so if those who follow the
work, our work, I use that
term to describe this.
It's basically saying hey we
have a memory system and
it makes predictions.
The second thing is we know
that there's a hierarchy of regions
and that in those hierarchy regions
I speculate that a sequence memory and
with that sequence memory we can do
inference or pattern recognition,
prediction, anomaly detection,
and motor generation.
There's a lot of things we
don't know about this yet but I'm
arguing that's the basic principle of
what's going on in each layer in each
region of the hierarchy.
We call that hierarchical
temporal memory because
it's basically describing the hierarchy
of temporal memory regions.
And then finally this is
the work I described today
which is really recent,
happened the last three years,
where I'm arguing that each layer of cells
in a region is a sequence memory.
So we've got maybe five layers of cells in
typical region of cortex, each one is
learning some type of sequence for
various reasons, feed-forward, feedback,
motor control, and so on.
It's based on sparse
distributed representations,
we now have a much better idea of what's
sparse distributed
representations are about.
It explains why there's columns
and why, how those columns are
representing the feed flow data.
There's a lot of physical,
biophysical, excuse me,
physiological data
which matches with this.
It explains how cells in
the column can represent the
feed-forward data in different contexts.
Because I want for the first time that
I'm aware of we have a model of why
cells have so many, have nonlinear
dendrites and how there's so many
synapses on them, and why they're
distributed the way they are and why
they grow the way they are.
And whether you, I'm pretty
confident these ideas
are basically correct but
if nothing else they work
and they're really cool and they do a
lot of things we've been trying to do
and they solve a lot of constraints.
We call that the cortical learning
algorithm because it's basically saying
hey we think this is the basic learning
mechanism that's going on between groups
of cells and distributed memory
formations and we're pretty excited
about that.
Okay, we have a long way to go but this
actually, my mind it may seem like not
much for 30 years, but this is actually
pretty good, I'm really happy with this,
and I'm gonna tell you about tomorrow
how we actually build this stuff and how
we're applying it to problems and some
of the, you know, how do we turn
this into, like, really intelligent
machines but there's a long way to go
there but this is enough to get started.
And that's what we're trying to do.
I want to end here with
just a couple pictures.
This is a picture of the
Redwood Neuroscience Institute on the
last day before it became the Redwood
Center for Theoretical Neuroscience.
There's Bruno and myself and there's
Tony Bell and a few other people and
there's the people at Numenta now.
Obviously all this work is team effort,
nothing is done individually and these
are the people I've worked
with over the years.
So that's it thank you very much.
(applauding)
- Question.
Where do the patterns get their
representational capacity?
That is, I like
the example of the different
senses of the word to,
the infinitive, the numeral, and
of course there must be something
corresponding in the brain to that and
what the picture will show us there a set
of patterns of neurons.
Now what fact about the patterns makes
them represent different
meanings of the word to?
- All right so the question,
I'm gonna repeat that and because everyone
didn't hear it or 'cause I get to
interpret it the way I want so I get to
answer the question that I want to answer.
(laughing)
Which is how do we learn, how
do those representations of
those bits, how do they come about
where do those different
representations come from?
The semantic meaning of those bits.
What makes them represent 'em?
Well first we have to realize
starting right at the senses
they have they have semantic meaning.
Right coming off the
retina or coming off the cochlea they have
semantic meaning.
It may not be the kind of
meaning you think of semantic
meaning, but I can say oh this ganglion
cell in the cochlea represents a range
of frequencies in the sound pattern and
this one coming off the retina means I
have an edge of, I have a certain
sort of on-off pattern in this
particular point of my visual space.
These are sort of small semantic meanings
but they're there from the
beginning and what happens in the
hierarchy, and we understand this mostly
but not a 100%, what
happens in the hierarchy
as you as you take a whole bunch of
converging sparse representations and
you run it through that first activity
I told you there where you project to the
proximal synapses, what it does is it
forms new representations that are
combinations with the old ones, and it
forms the representations
that are most common.
So when we did this in the visual system,
I didn't show this, we would end up,
I would take, like, bit
patterns from a retina and we'd end up
forming the kind of patterns you see in
V1 which are lying orientation segments
or different types of patterns you'd see
in the world and we tested this in
various ways and so now you have a
little bit more sophisticated
a representation of a bit.
Then we learn sequences of those.
So what we now when we learn sequences
of those representations, now we have
cells that are essentially saying
okay, this is this spatial feature in
a sequence and it's a lot of like the
sort of complex cells in V1 where you
say okay it's anything in this movement
in this direction.
And you do this over and over
again in the hierarchy and as
you go up the hierarchy you find more and
more complex patterns.
A lot of people who have been
working on this the idea for
many years in vision but I think what
they've really missed in a strong way is
how to use time in sequence memory in
addition to this combining a bit so you
have these, you've this forming new
spatial patterns that are the common
patterns from sequences of those and new
ones of those and honestly I can't say I
understand it all but in the end
that's how it has to come out of that.
And we've been able to exhibit up to a
certain level so perhaps not the fully
answer you'd like but it's the best I
can give today.
Yes this gentleman.
- [Man] Have you gained any insight
into the purpose of sleep and
for instance why prolonged absence of
sleep distorts the mechanism of the
brain and sensory processing?
- You know, sleep is
another one of those areas
which has huge amount of literature on.
It is known very clearly that sleep is
necessary to live.
Sleep deprived people eventually die.
It's also known to consolidate memories.
There's a whole interplay
that I didn't talk about at
all here between the
hippocampus and the cortex.
The hippocampus is the location
of episodic memories, things you learn
very quickly and if you lose your
hippocampus you won't form any new
memories of the certain types and
it's believed that sleep has a way of
taking those some of the things that are
stored up in the hippocampus
and retraining them into the cortex.
We don't model that, we don't try to.
Until I find a need for it,
I'm not going to do that.
Now we're not trying to emulate humans.
We actually in this system
I showed you here we have no
concept of episodic memory.
We think we can add
that if we wanted to but
there's no need to at the moment and
we're able to learn these things without
remembering exact details of stuff,
so the short answer is
no we're not modeling,
we have some ideas how we
would, and we didn't gain any
insights why humans need to do that.
Alright thank you again, I'm gonna be
around here for a few minutes for those
who want to talk to me.
(applauding)
(light music)